did you wash your hands with soap if you
want to know the secret purpose to
Amanda's key and other hidden clues
about future Saw movies then stick
around to the end of this video
welcome to things you missed saw 3
brought back a lot of characters from
the first two movies we got to see a rig
Carrie Matthews and even Adam Stan
Heights who's played by the screenwriter
Leigh Whannell after writing the first
two movies Whannell would make saw three
his final installment before moving on
to dead silence and insidious in one
tweet he hilariously claims that he'd
prefer saw three as the end of the
series to be honest I think they should
have ended it at three I'll admit it I
haven't even seen saw five or six people
ask me questions about detective Hoffman
and I don't know what they're talking
about which is really funny because Lee
created the character of Hoffman he
shows up in saw three there are a lot of
clues in his story that leave the third
film up for a sequel I wonder what Leigh
Whannell would say to that I'm a liar
let's get in to the things you missed
[Music]
just like the first two movies saw three
opens with the lights this time it's the
flashlight that detective Matthews would
try to use to make his way out of the
nerve gas house the first proper trap of
the movie is the classroom trap and we
found out this one was never meant to be
escapable which doesn't fit jigsaws
pattern
I guess Amanda didn't spend enough time
in jigsaws workshop and spent a little
bit too much time at build-a-bear
workshop because she didn't properly
learn the rules for making a jigsaw game
then there's a curious line from Hoffman
all I have to do release himself and
beat you the chance walk out the door
before it went off all he had to do at
the time the line was written it could
have just been a red herring but
something later on in the film makes me
think it was an intentional clue about
sophomore it becomes clear to please
that someone other than jigsaw is
holding traps when they find another
inescapable one no Carrie that's not
what I meant when I said stream sniping
last week when I covered saw - I
mentioned how some of the traps draw
inspiration from real-life torture
devices in history the angel trap seems
to be a post-industrial revolution
version of the bloody a Viking execution
ritual that severed the victims ribs
from their spines the same thing happens
to detective Kerry after reaching into a
beaker of acid to get the key
where have I heard that before towards
the end of the movie we see a prototype
in John's work that's never seen used on
any victim in the series but may have
also been inspired by a historical
torture mechanism the strappado the
invention of the medieval Inquisition
which left its victims suspended by
ropes for extended periods of time to
the point of body part dislocation or
death there was a third torture device
inspired by real life in this film but
I'll come back to that later in this
video after seeing the fate of Charon
you were introduced to this movie's main
protagonist a surgeon named dr. lynn
denlon one of the big twists of this
movie reveals that she's actually the
wife of the man making his way through
the trials at gideon meat-packing plant
however if we look back there are plenty
of clues when we see her at the hospital
she's depressed and the only thing that
ends up springing her into action is
when she sees that the patient is a
child Lynne was unable to do anything to
save her and Jeff's child a Dylan who
was struck down by a drunk driver so she
probably couldn't bear to see another
child slip away then in her locker
there's a picture drawn for her by a
child but what we don't know at the time
is that it's a keepsake from her lost
son Dylan the drawing of the pig matches
what was Dylan's favorite toy a plush
pig that looks like it could be from the
other mother in Coraline yes if you want
to stay here so sharp you won't feel it
perhaps it should have been clear when
Jeff makes his way through his trials
and at every step he's rewarded with a
ripped piece of his family photo the mom
is deliberately kept from us until the
end moments before we discover that Lin
and Jack are a married couple but the
hints about their relationship weren't
the only windows into the events that
would take place at the end of this
movie another twist that takes place as
the kidnapping of Jeff England's
daughter Corbett's to be used as
motivation for a game for Jeff in the
scene where Jeff is kidnapped by jigsaws
apprentice there are also very short
flashes of Corbett's face suggesting
that she too was taken in jigsaw
explains the rules of the game to Jeff
of deaths you will have to suffer to
move forward through each of them you
will finally come face to face with the
man responsible for the loss of your
child we assume that he's talking about
Timothy the drunk driver responsible for
Dylan's death but when jigsaw says you
will come face-to-face with the man
responsible for the loss of your child
he's really talking about himself the
man responsible for Corbett's kidnapping
Geoff's final test is to try to forgive
John Kramer who put him through the
whole day's worth of suffering Corbett
is locked away in an unknown location
inside Gideon a part of jigsaws plan
that is perhaps hinted at by the sketch
in the operating I have an eye looking
through a keyhole could the key that
Amanda wears throughout the movie a key
that we never learned the purpose of
possibly be the key that unlocks
Corbett's cell while following the
pathways of Lynn and Jeff have led us to
some things you missed the biggest
revelations will come when we take a
look at this game's main test subject
Amanda
the true suprise of saw 3 was the
deception of Amanda's status as a
facilitator of the game rather than a
player the final scene reveals that
jigsaw was really looking at her when he
began the game but the rules can apply
to both Lin and Amanda in a flashback we
see Amanda surviving the reverse bear
trap from the first movie after which
jigsaw takes her for her rebirth there
are a couple items in Amanda's room
within the gideon meat-packing plant
that symbolized it like this Botticelli
painting titled The Birth of Venus and a
jigsaw puzzle piece Amanda supposedly
has the survival instinct that jigsaw
victims lacked the failed subjects had
their piece taken from them while Amanda
got to keep hers please figure it out
that the traps at the beginning are
unwinnable and I mentioned back in my
saw one episode that I think Adams chain
was tampered with as well we see the
bathroom game being set up in a
flashback in saw 3 and Amanda tosses
Adams key into the bath while John is
not located I think the key was supposed
to be somewhere where Adam had a chance
to get it giving him the ability to roam
around the bathroom by undoing his
shackle in the montage at the end
Amanda's placement of the key is
accompanied by the narration Durham's
were unwinnable there's also a point
where John is speaking to lynn denlon
about his moral values and sheds light
i'm the reason that we would eventually
find out for Amanda being tested once
again I don't condone her and I
two spies markers which is a fine stance
to have but you have to apply it to
yourself as well John should be holding
himself accountable for the deaths of
the victims that he put into his many
traps so let's take a closer look at
those if he asked me that Jeff is going
the wrong way I mean I'd be headed
towards those fresh and frozen beef
products when he arrives at the pig fat
trap the judge just won't stop running
his mouth to the point he started to
sound like a talkative video game NPC
telemarketer this trap is clever though
because it's more of an emotional
suffering that takes place whereas the
others focus on physical pain I think
it's the only trap in the series so far
that's like that it's also pretty metal
drowning in the guts of a dead rotten
enemy I hate to say it but have to be
contradictory but it's very little the
challenges for Jeff to burn his late
son's possessions to obtain a key that
will free the judge from being drowned
in pig guts the key is hidden in Dylan's
favorite toy which was a pig as I
mentioned before pigs represents rebirth
because the year of the pig in the
Chinese zodiac is associated with the
concept of being reborn for jigsaw being
reborn is the idea of leaving your past
life behind and becoming to appreciate
and cherish the joy of being alive so
that's why there are pigs all over this
movie I already mentioned Dylan's
drawing inside of Lin's locker there's
also these little porkers up here the
pig masks worn by John's disciples these
guys in the operation room and the pig
hidden at the top of Jeff's study let's
move on to the next trap what was the
point of that this trap is another
example of a trap that's based off of a
real-world torture device from history
but this one you're probably familiar
with the cross has long been a religious
symbol for some but it gets its shape
from the ancient punishment known as
crucifixion looking at the rack makes me
think of a more technologically advanced
crucifix I've talked a little bit about
how John tries to make his following
very cult-like but he doesn't just draw
influence from one religion there were
also what I believe to be Buddhist
figures with him by his deathbed and
I've also heard that the spirals that
he's incorporated into much of his work
have connections to Buddhism as well I
think that the imagery connected to the
cult of jigsaw doesn't stop with
religion now he's also taking ideas from
other cultures like how we see the
Chinese concept of yin and yang
referenced right here and he also has
illustrations of the solar system
because there are certain cultures we
put a lot of significance on the solar
calendar I see the jigsaw cult is kind
of a melting pot of different religions
and cultures with an emphasis on
suffering to find enlightenment jigsaw
wears robes resembling those of a monk
in the scene where Amanda is reborn
the room is lit by candlelight and the
music that plays is titled baptism in
the official school
[Music]
one more note on the rack though rather
than having the feet together like you
typically see on a crucifix the feet are
parts like the second position seen on
Leonardo da Vinci's famous drawing the
Vitruvian Man which happens to be posted
up all over the operating room where
that part of John's game takes place
right about now you're probably thinking
that this jigsaw guy is really sharp the
kind of guy that's so smart he wears the
watch on the inside of his wrist only
problem is you might want to turn on
your camera there okay boomer
unlike saw - there's only one horror
reference I caught in this one and keep
in mind when you see this Annabelle doll
this was years before the conjuring or
Annabelle came out so this is a
reference to the actual real-life creepy
doll that those movies are based on if
that I have done episodes on all the
Annabelle movies but I've yet to cover
the main line conjuring trilogy though
that doesn't sound like a bad idea as a
franchise to do after I cover a song now
that may or may not be a hint at what's
coming next on this channel but one
person who definitely left him said what
would follow despite saying it should
have ended after Psalm 3 was the
screenwriter duly went out the first
hint was early on in the movie when John
Kramer discusses his relationship with
dr. Gordon interesting choice of words
but it also seems like the original plan
for Jeff was to have him survive and
play another game in soft form as I
discussed the ending alludes to a game
where he has to save his daughter
responsible for the loss of your child I
am the only person
Oh
jigsaw also gives a cryptic warning
telling Jeff that it would be dangerous
to try to move his dying one though you
may not see any threat all around you in
saw three we don't really have any idea
what he means by this but in saw four we
wouldn't meet the threats that approach
just beyond that door
obviously the storyline did change in
the year that would follow to where Jeff
was no longer the focus but you're not
off the hook just yet
Leigh Whannell remember that tweets I
find it a little suspicious that
Hoffmann was introduced in saw 3 left is
one of the only survivors and that this
shots which has nothing to do with saw 3
was added 6 start the beginning I'm
sophomore so if you want to hear about
all the new things you missed that saw 4
had to offer and then remember to
subscribe this Easy's worlds for new
Horrors every week wring that death
battle for notifications and I'll see
you in the next one
assuming we both survive and wash your
hands